let's turn your work at the VA you said
you want to make the VA the most
transparent organization in government
yes is lack of transparency really the
VA is biggest problem well I do think
it's one of our biggest problems we have
systemic issues that are big problems
but at the VA we don't have a stock
price so I can't follow how we're doing
so my stock price is the trust that we
have with our veterans and we actually
track that and the only way I know how
to regain the trust that we lost back in
2014 with our wait time crisis is to be
transparent to talk about the problems
and to show the progress and areas that
we still are struggling in so we now
publish all of our wait times for
patients across the country we're the
only health system in the country that
does that we publish our satisfaction
scores our quality ratings I published
our disciplinary actions every week on
employees that we removed from service
and now I even publish my travel
schedule because I believe that it's
important to be transparent about issues
that Americans are concerned about I
noticed that I noticed even had visits
with CBS news crew on your transparent
schedule yeah um I know you mentioned
but since 2014 and this is of course the
weightless scandal that involved the VA
hospital in Phoenix our wait times
better since then we've done several
things when I came to the VA there was
no clinical priority system so every
veteran waited the same time no matter
if they had an urgent issue or an
elective issue that they needed to be
taken care of and so now we prioritize
our patients by clinical priority so any
patient that has an urgent issue can be
seen every one of our VA medical centers
has same-day services and primary care
and mental health and we're continuing
to make progress and work on whittling
down our wait times in some parts of the
country it's tougher than others because
it's hard to get health care
professionals particularly in rural
areas but I can tell you where I
practice here in Manhattan I work in the
same day clinic and I can tell you that
if there's a patient who needs to be
seen here today I
confident they will be seen on the same
day the scandal at the time which was
exposed in Phoenix was that you had
hundreds if not a thousand veterans
across the country who while waiting for
care died unacceptable right of course
absolutely unacceptable absolutely
unexpected consequence better yes they
are and they're certainly better in
Phoenix but it doesn't mean that they're
completely where we want them to be we
have a lot more work we have 40,000
openings that we're trying to hire
vacancies jobs to fill jobs to fill so
we have a lot that we're still working
on and one of the reasons why I
published the wait times is to show
those areas where we still have more
work to do but certainly we have made a
lot of progress since 2014 and one of
the reasons is working with Congress
this choice program we now get patients
that are waiting out into the community
into the private sector to be able to
get the care that they need and that's
the system that I embrace which is
working to strengthen the VA at the same
time while working with the private
sector part of the reason I wanted to
sit down with you is because I've
watched this issue since 2014 but the
debt is not entirely clear that the wait
program has gotten better
mm-hmm I mean let's let's let's get
specific here I mean according to your
own internal ranking system Phoenix is
still among the lowest quality VA
hospitals in the United States yes yes
that's not better
well what let's break it down when I
first came to the VA we had 57,000
patients who are waiting for urgent
consult today we would have less than a
few hundred so in the area of matching
the clinical need of the patient to when
they're being seen we've made tremendous
progress and that's where we're focused
to make sure that we don't ever repeat
where they're veterans waiting for Karen
are harmed by that weight in the issue
of Phoenix in the way that we measure
quality Phoenix while it is definitely
improving and there are metrics to show
that it's improving has a long way to go
and this is a part of the country where
we've seen such an influx of veterans
due to retirement ages and people moving
to that area we've had trope we've had
trouble keeping up with it we've opened
up two major ambulatory centers around
our major Phoenix Medical Center and as
those open up and as we're filling our
positions there we're going to continue
to make progress and things are
improving there but it still has a ways
to go